nous avons réalisé les études et en
interrogeant les participants c'est qui
qui serait en invité le plus intéressant
évidemment les réponses étaient toujours
que c'était un président poutine mais
c'est un peu délicat de l'inviter à
participer à notre forum mais en fin de
compte nous avons su inviter le ministre
des affaires étrangères qui avec la
gentillesse a trouvé ces deux heures à
nous consacrer dans son agenda très
chargé pour échanger avec nous avec vous
c'est pourquoi nous commençons notre
forum avec une journée d'avancé c'est
maintenant même ici même que j'annonce
le vingt cinquième
forum de journalisme moderne être ouvert
pour donner le message du président de
la fédération de russie se passe la
parole au ministre des affaires
étrangères de la fédération de russie
sergueï lavrov bonjour chers amis
merci beaucoup pour votre invitation est
avant tout comme vient de le dire mais
ce seul avion pour remplir ce qui m'a
été demandé
je vais lire le message au 25e forum des
journalistes
bienvenue à sotchi pour ce forum
ce forum avait commencé en
1996 et il a été significatif pour la
russie pour les régions pour l'aimer
pour les différents médias qui
travaillent dans ce domaine il a permis
à de soutenir leur prestige de cette
profession on sait que aujourd'hui le
rôle du journaliste est particulièrement
important dans la société la l'ordre du
jour est très riche
et les gens ont besoin d'information
offert c'est
pour à l'occasion de la remise du prix
défi multimédia je félicite ceux qui
vont être les récipiendaires de ce prix
ce concours a permis de régner de
représentants de tous les secteurs de la
presse du journalisme tant les jeunes
que les plus expérimentés et cela
renforce
le journalisme en russie et je suis
convaincu que l'organisation sera au
plus haut niveau
toutes les présentations table ronde qui
sont organisées ici permettent un
échange d'idées nouvelles et de
projets
meilleure soirée à tous la dîmière
footing
de ma part je voudrais dire deux mots et
avant tout merci d'avoir été invité je
suis toujours heureux d'avoir la
possibilité de m'exprimer devant vous
dans ce format de discussion tout à fait
ouverte et qui est toujours productif
nous vivons une période d'explosion
médiatique et ne comprenons que
l'efficacité de chaque mesure politique
ne peut être que renforcée si elle
trouve un écho positif dans la presse un
écho objectif de jours il ya deux jours
nous avons fêté
la journée des journalistes de leur
solidarité et
on a salué la mémoire de ceux qui ont
perdu la vie dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions
parmi eux anne christine et gore cogne à
look anton vallot chine
et qui sont décédés dans le sud est de
l'ukraine et je pense que la discussion
d'aujourd'hui
pourraient être construites justement
autour de vos souhaits je suis prêt à
répondre à toutes vos questions à
commenter les sujets abordés et mais
c'est important de voir comment vous
vous percevez notre travail et nous
apprécions particulièrement
ce que vous écrivez sur nous y compris
les articles peuvent être critique
cela ne sert de conseils de suggestions
et aujourd'hui quand
le champ médiatique est envahi par des
nouvelles qu'elles soient vraies ou
qu'elle soit fait qu est qu elle se
diffuse partout dans le monde dans notre
pays aussi
c'est important de soutenir le
journalisme honnête qui s'appuie sur des
faits sur des faits vérifiés et qui est
dictée par le respect envers cette
profession
je voudrais parler et je pense qu'on
peut utiliser tous les exemples qui vous
sembleront opportun on peut passer à vos
questions et si vous me le permettez je
vais m'asseoir
messieurs ministre avant de commencer
notre échange je voudrais vous
représentez l'audience vous dire qui est
présent
oui l'union des journalistes de russie
c'est parmi les unions les plus
importants de la russie union
professionnelle nous avons 85 bureaux
régionaux
nous voyons ici les représentants de
multiples bureaux qui auront su finir en
peu à l'avancé un autre feu roma
aujourd'hui ici et ona déjà a
entendu aujourd'hui dans le message de
président vous trouvez ici les membres
du conseil de menace ion 2 défi
multimédia qui vient d'être annoncée ces
deux manquent nous allons remettre ce
prix pour la première fois elle est
important que ce ne seront pas seulement
les représentants des télévisions qui
seront éclairés mais les représentants
de tous les secteurs des médias modernes
parmi nous
nous avons les dirigeantes des
journaux les plus importants je vois
d'été cherniak les revers de rang chez
oddo comme un des facteurs des
tricheries qui
qui était très difficile à faire sortir
de la prison on criait nous avons nos
collègues
serbe nos collègues qui ont créé l'
agence express russe le monde de haut
est allé courir les journalistes et
russes qui ont étaient décédées et ont
péri en yougoslavie et alors nos
collègues serbe aide nos journalistes à
travailler dans le pays eux ils ont
aussi des questions à vous poser je peux
en parler pendant très longtemps mais je
tiens seulement souligné que nous aurons
ici le fleuron de notre journalisme les
représentants de nombreux pays du monde
alors allons commencer
notre échange et si vous permettez j'ai
profité de mon rôle de modérateur pour
vous poser la première question nous
nous les collègues et surtout ceux qui à
vos passe maintenant en direct nos
intérêts sont vraiment à ce qui se passe
actuellement cet agenda à l'actuel
comment notre ministère des affaires
étrangères a réagi à au message du
président crayon
malgré les technologies de pointe je ne
sais pas cette
déclaration il veut faire la guerre
quand son ministre de la défense où le
chef d'état major
a dit que
il serait prêt à conquérir les régions
de donetsk est lougansk
et que des dizaines de milliers de
personnes pourraient périr c'est une
logique intéressante
il ya une réponse
et qu'est ce qu'il a dit simplement j'ai
pas vu sa réponse
moi non plus j'ai pas vu un détail alors
qui sait
alors je sais qu'après lui quelqu'un
dans son cabinet a dit que l à l'heure
actuelle c'est peu probable
donc
on peut avoir différentes perceptions du
temps mais j'ai choisi une citation
à stanford le président les hans qui
quand il était en visite ce dernier
lille et dis nous serons forts
un périple hui sans leader de l'europe
j'en suis convaincu parce que tout est
possible alors peut-être que tout est
possible
une guerre avec la fédération de russie
je sais pas mais en tout cas les
commentaires ne sont pas forcément
nécessaire l'ascension n'était pas
nécessaire aussi sur cette déclaration
imprégné de russophobie et je trouve
regrettable que le président
les uns ce qui suit une voie qui est
toute différente
de celle qu'il avait permis d'avoir le
soutien même de la population de l'est
de l'ukraine
et si tu vis en ukraine qui était conçu
quand tu es tu te considères russe alors
retourne en russie il avait dit ça
aujourd'hui une a7 toute déclaration
en réponse à une question s'il se
représentera il avait dit
j'irai d'abord remplir tout ce que j'ai
promis pour mon premier mandat et
ensuite on verra donc nous voyons très
très bien aujourd'hui on peut faire des
commentaires sans arrêt sur les
initiatives
les sept îles qui sont faites et on voit
que c'est un
travail de sape contre les accords de
minsk
je vois ici encore un commun un écho de
kpn du spectacle humoristique francs
russe cavernes mais je dirais que c'est
regrettable
nous soutenons
nous répétons sans arrêt que nous sommes
prêts à avoir un dialogue ouvert parce
que le dire le peuple ukrainien et d'un
peuple proches frères du peuple russe on
l'a déjà dit souvent et donc
on dit parfois que les peuples ont les
dirigeants qu'ils méritent
voilà
mettant vos questions si le play timor
shafi le dirigeant de
département international de l'union des
journalistes de russie
ce lavrov si on part de ce sujet de kpn
et c'est au kit le sujet des spectacles
humoristiques et on parle de la
politique réelle d'après votre énorme
expérience et qui parmi le partenaire
parmi les dirigeants des ministère des
affaires étrangères parmi vos homologues
vous pouvez nommer comme de vrais
professionnels
avec qui c'était en
intéressant c'était le plaisir de
travailler nonobstant du fait de la
facilité aux difficultés de ce travail
de ces échanges les top 3 pour vous les
trois premiers je ne voudrais avec ces
personnes la majorité l'écrasante
majorité de mes partenaires
sont de très grands très grands
professionnels et je crains même de
citer des normes m23 même 10 je voudrais
pas
offensé quelqu'un mais je pense que tous
les ministres affaires étrangères ont
atteint un objectif c'est de défendre
des intérêts de leur pays et c'est ce
principe que nous suivons et ça
correspond à la conception de notre
politique étrangère c'est à dire réunir
les conditions les plus favorables pour
le développement de la russie pour le
son développement économique son
développement social le bien-être de la
population et assurer la sécurité du
pays et la défense des droits des
citoyens russes qui sont résidents ou en
voyage à l'étranger où qu'ils soient et
la défense de nos entrepreneurs c'est
qu'ils sont objets qui font l'objet de
discrimination actuellement actuellement
gelée dit à plusieurs reprises nous
sommes obligés de prendre en compte dans
ce travail qui consiste à réunir les
conditions favorables
nous devons prendre en compte la ligne
politique que je suis ce que sur les
pays occidentaux contre la russie déjà
bien avant les événements
d'ukraine et les premières sanctions
date est de bien avant
et donc cette ligne politique
occidentale
est justifiée par le fait que les états
unis ce sont affligés de leurs pertes de
domination mondiale de leur puissance
économique financière politique
il estime qu'il faut mettre un fera au
centre de force qui sont alternativement
et qui freine donc ce processus de
multipolarité dans le monde dont il
cherche à contenir la russie et la chine
et donc c'est ce dessin occidental qui
se manifeste ici
donc il ya des menaces transfrontalières
qui existent et qui ne laisse personne
indifférent kessel sus
de la pandémie du terrorisme des trafics
de drogue
etc les menaces sont nombreux
et qu'ils se sont renforcés et qui
menace l'ensemble de l'humanité et pour
résoudre ces problèmes
on ne peut le faire qu'en travaillant de
concert ensemble au delà par delà les
frontières les comptes de compte tenu du
fait que les pays occidentaux dirigée
par les états unis entrent en
confrontation avec la russie en
utilisant des sanctions illégales une
concurrence malsaine
bien évidemment quand on voit cette
approche
nous réagissons en faisant ce qu'on
appelle au sens le plus large la
substitution à l'import à l'importation
c'est à dire que nous cherchons
développer
notre position il ya cette réaction qui
ne concerne pas semblant les les
produits
de consommation vss ça concerne les
autres technologies la défense et tous
les secteurs qui peuvent être décisifs
pour assurer la sécurité et la vie de
nos citoyens
on n'est pas du tout dans une logique de
confrontation d'isolement au contraire
on travaille avec tous ceux qui sont
prêts à travailler avec nous sans
utilisation sans utiliser de d'ultimatum
de sanctions etc
et nous ne nous référons à la
l'expérience de négociation de
discussions et nous sommes prêts à
recommencer dès demain à discuter avec
tous mes temps que
on n'a pas d'assurance
et qu'on n'a pas de confiance vis-à-vis
de nos partenaires nous devons prendre
en compte tout cela et nous devons
veiller à défendre nos intérêts
dans la défense et la défense de notre
vie aussi et quand on est confronté à
quelqu'un je reviens à votre question
originale si on voit quelqu'un
qui défend les intérêts de son pays et
met aux dépens de l'intérêt des autres
et à ce moment là il va inventer
des arguments
qui iront contre l'union des forces pour
le bien général et mais j'ai des inrocks
je respecte tout à fait parce que ils
ont des objectifs qu'ils se sont fixés
qui ne remplissent donc je vais pas
citer je m'attendais de personnes
peut-être qu'au cours de notre
discussion je t'aide c'était un ou deux
noms
comme participant de tel ou tel de
discussions mais je pense que dans
l'ensemble oui ce sont des gens qui sont
des professionnels
respectés
voilà c'est à dire que s'il ya des
attaques eh bien on riposte à ces
attaques
notre collègue serbe watching praga
que présente express russe il parle très
bien russe naulleau si novatrice
commentant des
bonjour monsieur le ministre j'ai une
question nous avons
nous n'avons pas eu de problèmes à venir
en russie avec le test pcr négatif
c'était tout à fait facile quand est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à la même chose de
la part de l'union européenne
on comprend nos tous que ce serait plus
facile de vivre
si les possibilités existent et de
reconnaissance mutuelle des vaccins en
ce qui concerne ces vaccins
pensez vous qu'il s'agit d'un moyen de
d'exercer la pression occidentale sur la
fédération de russie je tiens à
mentionner que la serbie grâce de dieu a
adoptée a reconnu le vaccin russe et a
même lancé la fabrication sur son
territoire national et en profite pour
faire vacciner la population
nous sommes en pays nous avons favorisé
cette approche si les gens ont besoin de
l'aide il faut le faire sans y faire
appliquer la politique vous avez raison
à propos de l'opportunité de la
cohérence
de cette approche
ça continue ça poursuit la discussion
sur la question précédente il ya des
intérêts mondiaux généraux
si on les résout en utilisant des
considérations géopolitiques en
cherchant à exercer une dissuasion en
empêchant la coopération par le compte
concrètement de
l'union européenne il ya la chance
européenne des médicaments
elle a justement aujourd'hui son
représentant aujourd'hui ouvrière a dit
qu il aurait besoin d'un temps
supplémentaire
peut-être la fin de cette année le début
de l'année prochaine pour étudier tous
les vaccins et les enregistrer
ça fait longtemps
que nos structures liées à la santé
publique travaillent sur cette voie avec
l'union européenne
et il ya effectivement des facteurs
objectifs
parce que le premier contact entre nos
spécialistes et ceux de l'union
européenne
avant ça il n'y avait pas eu de
discussion et or là on voit qu'il ya un
certain nombre de questions
qui sont apparues et qui sont
indispensables pour le nom européenne
et qui n'ont pas été
prises en compte ici c'est ni bon ni
mauvais simplement c'est une méthode qui
est différente et ensuite concerne
spots tv c'est à dire que il faut voir
la pratique
il n'y a pas eu
d'accident je cherche même pas à
comparer avec les autres vaccins mais
si la discussion se faisait de façon
professionnelle je pense que un accord a
été trouvé depuis longtemps et
d'ailleurs la chance européenne
de médicaments pourraient enfin certain
nombre d'organismes attendent une excuse
de cette agence un certain nombre de
pays alors que chaque pays pourrait
prendre une décision au niveau national
utiliser la hongrie a été le premier
pays la slovaquie a fait également et
ils n'ont pas été punis
avec la plus part de nos partenaires on
voit que la plupart auraient préféré une
décision rapide et positive de cette
façon
certains ont voulu prendre des décisions
nationales donc la porte est ouverte à
tous les autres en ce qui concerne la
politisation oui je me souviens au début
de l'année par exemple président macron
avait accusé la russie et la chine
de politiser la question des vaccins
et ou sous la forme de relais avaient
utilisé ça aussi à l'automne dernier
elle avait dit qu'il fallait s'appuyer
uniquement sur les vaccins occidentaux
et donc on voit que la chance
européenne des médicaments avait
signé des contrats
d'achat de différents vaccins occident
avant même de les avoir enregistré donc
si on veut un peu de bon sens ici
il faut il faut qu'il y ait une décision
on a des décisions un peu triviale qui
ont été prises ici autre exemple
le gouvernement de san marin
ils nous ont demandé de
livrer
ce vote nick v pour toute leur
population c'est pas très nombreux c'est
cinquante mille soixante mille habitants
et
aujourd'hui ils ont une demande énorme
et c'est un tourisme vaccinale c'est à
dire que les gens viennent exprès là bas
pour se faire vacciner
et les ex les italiens ne reconnaissent
pas vaccin vrai mais san marin
tout habitant de
un habitant de san marin peut circuler
en italie avec un certificat de
vaccination au spoutnik et récemment
j'étais à rome j'ai attiré l'attention
là-dessus
auprès de mon homologue
mais ils ont dit oui effectivement et
bientôt les habitants de samara ne
pourront pas circuler avec les vaccins
russe alors c'est vous savez que quand
le président poutine il ya un peu plus
d'un an avait annoncé justement que nous
étions en train d'élaborer un vaccin il
avait dit déjà tu nous étions
complètement ouvert à toute coopération
en la matière
et donc il y avait une réunion qui se
tenait en
visioconférence il avait donc soutenu la
décision
pour que pendant la période de pandémie
on puisse oublier
le caractère
de brevets d
vaccin tels que les pays aucun pays
producteurs n'a renoncé à cela
aujourd'hui
donc il ya eu quelques murmures qui ont
été dits ça a été ça a disparu ensuite
vaccins par bruxelles a parlé de
reconnaissance mutuelle de vaccins et
ces jours ci il ya une rencontre à rome
du g20 il ya une rencontre entre les
ministres de la santé et notre ministre
a dit oui on pourrait on reconnaître les
certificats de vaccination
sur la part des décisions nationales et
tout ça traîne dans l'air et on nous
reproche
nous de lancer une guerre de vaccin dès
on nous accuse aussi de soutenir le
mouvement anti vaccinales qui demande on
nous accuse nous donne là donc
si quelqu'un a en tête fermement ancrée
qu'il fallait absolument exercer une
dissuasion une contention en lega de la
russie l'accuser de tous les faits qu de
toutes les accusations ne peut rien
faire
nous notre porte est ouverte
alors maintenant quelqu'un du milieu de
la salle barraute escales cofondateur en
chef du journal barge tartastan et chef
de l'union des journalistes et
républicaine s'il vous plaît vous le
micro dont la capitale produit justement
aussi le spoutnik v
bonsoir monsieur lavrov évidemment dans
notre capitale on a lancé après la
fabrication du vaccin
ma question concerne
la guerre nous tous mais gardons de près
la situation en afghanistan aux
frontières de l'ex urss nous sommes
nombreux à me rappeler de la guerre en
afghanistan dans les années 1980 à votre
point de vue c'est le guerre offrons à
nos frontières est ce que c'est en
minimes menace quel sera le
développement de la situation d'après
vous est ce que les taliban s'ils ont
reconnu par la communauté internationale
ou pas en ce qui concerne le danger les
risques dans cette région ils ont
toujours existé et l'objectif des
alliances qui ont été mises en place par
la russie et ses partenaires notamment
dans l'organisation de shanghai
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective c'est pour
justement de tra lisez ces risques avec
les talibans nous n'avons pas cessé le
dialogue depuis quelques années et nous
sommes pas les seuls les américains
discutent avec eux aussi mais la chine
aussi et d'autres pays de la région
et nous avons parlé avec eux sur la base
d'une résolution ferme du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu qui disent justement
que toutes les décisions politiques se
font sur la base des discussions avec
les talibans
c'est
donc 40 45 % de la population pachtoune
qui est soutien l'état les banques et
donc pour résoudre la situation actuelle
face à ne peut être fait que dans un
discussions nationales avec les tadjiks
ouzbeks et les autres ethnies du pays
et quand le président afghan a quitté le
pays précipitamment les talibans saisis
les derniers territoires et les talibans
ont dit qu'il n'avait aucune intention
d'usurper le pouvoir mais qui voulaient
faire établir un gouvernement qu'il
n'avait aucune intention
de créer des problèmes alors voisin en
l'occurrence les pays d'asie centrale et
qui n'ont pas l'intention de pénétrer
dans les pays d'asie centrale et qu'ils
allaient lutter contre il était aux
risques sur le territoire de
l'afghanistan
en l'occurrence g de dèche et d'al qaïda
et pour l'instant il semble respecter
cet engagement et nous avons eu des
discussions
en visioconférence puisque nous avons
une conférence des
deux lots tsc avec notamment
l'ouzbékistan qui ne fait pas partie de
cette alliance nous avons des contacts
au niveau militaire nous a eus nous
avons eu des manoeuvres au tadjikistan
notamment
et nous sommes prêts à tout mais nous
n'avons pas de raison aujourd'hui de
voir une menace
reversement
dans les pays qui sont nos alliés mais
nous faisons tout pour être prêt à toute
éventualité et en même temps
des conférences nombreuses sont
organisés
qui autour de thèmes 2 du règlement
politique et ça c'est ce que j'ai dit
c'est à dire c'est un processus qui doit
être inclusif
pour le maintien sur le territoire
de la sécurité sur le territoire de
l'afghanistan et éviter détruire tous
les foyers de terrorisme et aujourd'hui
l'afghanistan
produit
90% de la drogue dans le monde et là
c'est un problème et il ya d'autres
questions qui sont à l'ordre du jour il
ya là la question du statut des femmes
des petites filles et c est ce que je
veux dire c'est que la stabilité dans la
région pour nous est une priorité
inconditionnel et lors des discussions à
l'onu
donc il ya aujourd'hui des discussions
qui sont menées à l'onu pour poursuivre
la la mission de maintien de la paix et
donc je pars cette décision de
poursuivre notre ambassade
fonctionne nous avons optimisé
les agences dire que les épouses et des
enfants sont partis
donc
l'ambassade fait un travail admirable et
nous fournissent des informations sur la
situation sur le terrain et nous
proposons d'organiser
une rencontre des cinq pays membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu avec les pays voisins de
l'afghanistan pakistan l'iran
l'irak est il yad'autres ce dès
le président l'italie président du g20
avaient proposé aussi de faire rimer
lyon là dessus et nous gardons sur la
table nos propositions
notamment dans le format moscou
iran pakistan inde chine etats unis et
russie
et c'est le levier
d'évolution
qui avec notamment la tre k
etats unis russie chine
à laquelle s'est joint le pakistan et
l'iran aussi
et l'un d'eux s'est donc notre approche
consiste n'est pas simplement de faire
une conférence avec peu importe qui
participent
mais au contraire mettre autour d'une
table tous ceux qui peuvent réellement
pas en paroles mais réellement avoir une
influence sur la situation sur le
terrain en afghanistan
une dernière question est ce que tu as
les manceaux ont reconnu par la
communauté internationale
ehpad on vous l'avait dit qu est-ce qu
importe aujourd'hui du fait qu'il faut
avoir des relations avec cet élément
même ceux qui ont évacué en ratent leur
ambassade ce que nous n'avons pas fait
et qu'un certain nombre de pays ont
laissé leurs représentations
diplomatiques sur place et donc parler
avec les libanais et les talibans pardon
sera inévitable en fonction de savoir si
les talibans vous
remplir
honoré leurs engagements
ici je pense que il y aura un examen de
la question de la reconnaissance ou me
merci beaucoup
axa nassau là bas qui dirige
l'édition dans la ville de l'est puisque
le journal de l'épiscopat jours
cela brosse vous avez déjà mentionné le
cren le président zelensky et son
gouvernement se sont permis de plusieurs
fois des annonces peu diplomatique à
l'encontre de nord stream et vous à
votre tour vous expliquer d'une façon
claire et compréhensible la position de
la russie à quand vous parlez aux médias
étrangers qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est ce que les médias traditionnels
peuvent véhiculer vos messages air eau
peu aux gens où il faut trouver de
nouvelles formes de communication qui
vise avait que les l'information aux
gens directement merci je crois qu'ici
ce forum la forme de selon laquelle
l'information est transmise et pas
forcément très importante mais les
technologies de pointe permettent de
faire de l'information un produit à
consommer très chaud
et qui peut perturber l'opinion publique
[Musique]
susciter des risques au contraire les
étouffer il ya notamment l'effet que
nous qui ont souvent cet effet-là donc
ici il faut s'appuyer sur les faits sur
des faits vérifiés mais on pourra jamais
se débarrasser des faits que nous ça
fait partie de notre horizon médiatique
sur l'arène internationale ait beaucoup
de nos partenaires vous avez qu'à voir
ce qu'ils ont dit qu'ils écrivent à
notre propos mais
ce qui est important pour eux
c'est à dire que la russie se comporte
mal sur l'arène internationale
ils
se disent qu'ils sont prêts à travailler
avec la russie à condition que la bleue
s'ils changent de comportement alors
c'est à dire rendez la crimée partait de
la crimée alors que personne ne nous a
vus là-bas et bien d'autres prétentions
pareil en moldavie en asie etc et si on
commence à citer des faits
les faits qui ont servi de base à la
situation géopolitique aujourd'hui par
exemple en ossétie du sud c'est ça cache
valley qui a mené une agression et qui
ensuite à un an après agressé nos
soldats de la paix qui sont morts de
l'offensive
direct et en 2009 l'union européenne
avait commandé un rapport spécial sur
les causes de cette guerre d'août 2008
et le rapport
rédigé par un groupe d'experts dirigé
par un expert finlandais avait conclu
que justement c'était un nom de sa cache
valley qui avait causé tout ça donc on
peut écrire dans les blocs dans les
réseaux sociaux
tout ce qu'on veut
mais si on veut pas écouter
alors ces deux objectifs par exemple en
ukraine
encore une fois
mon collègue le ministre des affaires
étrangères dit que nous travaillons à
créer un nouveau format
normandie nous allons travailler à
remplir les
accords de minsk mais en même temps un
membre du cabinet 2nd qui dit que le
groupe de contact
la délégation ukrainienne qui était dans
le groupe de contact de minsk se retire
donc on dit par exemple il faut que les
rebelles laisse la frontière et ensuite
après on pourra parler de du statut de
la langue russe d amnistie et c'est tout
le monde comprend très bien que c'est
incohérent comme proposition et qui va
complètement à l'encontre des accords de
minsk ensuite ils disent que
le format normandie c'est bien mais faut
y
inclure aussi les etats-unis la
grande-bretagne etc alors quand on parle
de forme en normandie nous demandons
d'abord d'expliquer comment vous allez
assemblée tout ça
il y à la question de la population
russophone d'utiliser sa langue
il yal amnistie pour les
ceux qui ont participé au
aux événements de 2014 lysiens la
question des élections locales à donetsk
et le grand disque pour définir leur
statut alors que tout ça est inscrit
et nos collègues d'allemagne et de
france
propose en marge de l'assemblée générale
de l'onu à new york de se réunir et de
parler de tout ça
donc nous avons une discussion pour
essayer de comprendre quelle est leur
position parce qu'on voit ce que
zelensky
est en train légiste
législativement de modifier ses
engagements or
là c'est une discussion qui n'est pas
sérieuse qui n'est pas professionnel et
quand on leur demande entre quatre yeux
quand vous demandez à la russie de
respecter des accords de minsk
là il ya cinq points dans ces accords et
il ya un point sur
la normalisation de 15 alors alors alors
qu'en réalité la russie n'est pas si tu
es là bas il s'agit de kiev donetsk de
lougansk etc nous ne sommes pas partie
au conflit dans le donbass donc je
propose de continuer à
continuer à discuter mais de façon
constructive sans
double sens
il est inscrit là bas que il faut
valider entre kiev et logan cette date
toutes les questions
alors qu'elle ambiguïté peut-on
reprocher si tout est écrit donc ils se
respectent pas un même parce que ces
gens ils ne veulent remplir ni les
engagements
de 2000 ce qu est ce de paris 2019
ils veulent inscrire
cela
dans la constitution de l'ukraine à
l'encontre des accords des masques donc
pour revenir à votre question vous savez
pour faire bref
je vois le journaliste
classique qui rentre chez lui et qui
brosse son ordinateur et qui devient
blogueurs
je vois encore encore quelqu'un qui veut
oui vous voulez juste dire merci à vous
poser une question juste remercier
mais étant donné qu'elle est assise
assez loin on va commencer par son
collègue commence ses ray-ban il est
secrétaire de l'union des journalistes
et responsables pour la politique des
jeunes et ensuite ce sera le tour de
cette jeune fille je vous remercie pour
la possibilité de poser la question
bonjour monsieur le ministre vous savez
en me rappelant du temps de l'union
soviétique et ce qui est un peu délicat
pour moi étant donné mon âge mais un
bref à l'époque de nombreux jeunes
journalistes et diplomates avaient
d'aller en
occident voir cette nouvelle vie faire
connaissance
d'autres pays touché de l'argent
pourquoi pas maintenant lorsque nous
regardons la situation actuelle à moscou
la situation actuelle que non seulement
être concurrentiel mais peut même
dépasser les paramètres pareil à à
l'étranger comme en maintenant les
jeunes diplômés les jeunes journalistes
après cissé a mission étrangers est ce
qu'ils sont alléchés par le pack
notre niveau jean despas pire et même si
certains plans il dépasse ce qu'il date
dans certains pays occidentaux
deuxièmement
bien évidemment les décisions qui ont
été prises par le président
eh bien peut-être plus de dix ans
elle a été longue à préparer pour donc
ses décisions sur
améliorer le les conditions matérielles
des diplomates et serait dans les années
90 c'était plutôt le contraire
et donc les responsables du ministère
commençait à partir dans des entreprises
privées parce qu'
il pouvait plus
vous n'êtes plus travaillé au ministère
et nos spécialistes nous interprète et
partait donc en nous avons avec le
président
améliorer le niveau de salaire et je
considère que actuellement nous sommes à
peu près au niveau moyen des pays
d'europe occidentale et
je pense qu'il ya certains représentants
de notre profession qui ne voulait pas
partir qu'ils étaient contents les
avaient leur famille leurs amis et leurs
parents ce
mais chez nous quand on est recrutée
conformément à la loi sur le statut
particulier du personnel diplomatique on
sait un accord disant qu' on est soumis
à rotation c'est à dire que on travaille
un certain temps au centre ensuite on
doit aller à l'étranger
il ya on trouve une solution entre les
les intérêts du ministère et les
intérêts dus de l'agent diplomatique
mais dans les cas où les gens refusent
une nomination ou il demande à ne pas
être nommé ça arrive c'est pas très
souvent parce que l'essentiel
comprennent que mettre en place former
un véritable professionnel il faut
travailler aussi à l'étranger et
comprendre cette partie qui est une
partie considérable de notre activité de
notre profession et sans cela dans les
postes dirigeants ministère on peut pas
travailler par manque d'expérience
justement donc
ici dans la majorité des cas nos agents
sont des gens ambitieux ils veulent
faire carrière
au maximum de façon visible
ils veulent être promu et on n'a pas ici
de
manque d'agents à l'étranger
n'a pas de manque de personnes
souhaitant travailler à l'étranger
le collègue qui a pu démontrer cette
pancarte où vous passe le micro vous
êtes venus de la city a présenté ou s'il
vous plaît nathalie gonthier rove
russie vesti sotchi et votre quel est
votre question
on peut faire connaissance
bonjour monsieur le ministre évidemment
avant tout je tiens à vous remercier
vous dire merci pour votre travail notos
ne comprenons que la russie est
actuellement sur une énorme pression et
dans ces conditions
compliquées vous continuer à protéger
les intérêts de la russie et à mon point
de vue personnel vous le faite de la
manière très vertueuse et
professionnelle
et ma question suivante durant la
session plénière de feu roma économique
et orientale le modérateur abri love a
posé la question au président
si ça serait sont
regrettables de laisser partir la
brevets chez vous pour participer à un
thomas d'état et poutine a répondu tout
court tellement ce serait regrettable et
quand vous est-ce que vous recruterez ce
départ et qu'est ce qui va vous manquer
donc
parmi vos obligations de mise des
affaires étrangères le président répondu
mais pendant seulement il est dommage
mais
c'est pour eux que c'est dommage donc en
fait c'est comme ça donc il faut
attendre les résultats des élections et
je préfère ne pas anticiper
aller
alors je pense que je vais pas m'ennuyer
en collègue qu'il venu de city une
collègue la nappe se vannent la chaîne
de télévision assez thierry sainte je
viens de vladikavkaz dit s'il vous plaît
d'après vous quel est le statut futur de
la city le sud
je vois là l'ossétie du sud comme un
pays souverain
le 26 août 2008 il ya eu donc eu une
décision populaire qui a été fait
devant la position du président géorgien
de l'époque saakashvili qui n'étaient
pas en tout dans toute
sa santé mentale et il ya une décision
qui a été prise par
et donc il y avait une décision de
l'otan de l'époque qui disaient que
l'ukraine et la géorgie à les faire
partie de l'otan et cela alors à
bien peu de poudre aux yeux
ils ceux ci sont son permis
de
prendre des décisions et vous savez que
la praille a elle aussi décidé de se
retirer de le juger
on a découvert d'ailleurs des entrepôts
d'armes en apprécie et des documents
des documents qui montrent et qu'après
le cd l'ossétie du sud ce serait autour
de la pratique de connaître un conflit
et donc nous avons reconnu
l'indépendance et la souveraineté de ces
deux pays et ces pays avaient besoin de
notre soutien d'ailleurs cette
déclaration de l'otan d'avril 2008 selon
laquelle la géorgie et l'ukraine ferez
partie de l'otan et aujourd'hui les
dirigeants de qu'elles sont aussi
possédé par cette
déclaration et 7 est ce statut de membre
de l'otan et ça excite les esprits et
quand on voit l'effondrement économique
et social l'effondrement des prix là bas
est donc cette
cette vision de leader
qu'il se voit comme leader de l'europe
donc
[Musique]
nos collègues de l'otan doivent
comprendre que deux
en faisant des déclarations pareilles il
pouvait susciter des réactions
aujourd'hui comprennent bien que c'est
des départs le rien que c'est une
entreprise tout à fait
perdue d'avancé
ossétie du sud est un état indépendant
sur décision populaire et elle
continuera à l'être
merci
un instant si je plais tour à tour mais
non nous n'allons pas oublier la sibérie
orientale je vois le dirigeant de
l'union à des journalistes mais tu
rigoles golovanoff qui vient de sibérie
mais seul le ministre c'est la question
qu'il faut poser absolument étant donné
que les élections approchent
nous savons qu à partir de 2003 la
russie unie est gagnante des élections
une barbe nous avons peu du doute
je vais fait transmettre vos pronostics
merci et
l'intervenant précédent a déjà mentionné
que moscou ne cédez pas au capital mon
dieu mondial mais en provence s est pas
vraiment le cas peut-être mais ma
question et suivantes peut-être au tour
des élections en joie ni mes bébés un
débat acharné
nos collègues journalistes entre autres
à y participent si on fait le cumul de
ces débats on peut dire qu'il s'agit à
d'une discussion alors que c'est bon
c'est la stabilité d'autres prétendent
que c'est du pop otage de la corruption
qui sont générés par la langue stabilité
à part la continuité de du pouvoir
surtout dans les régions et vous étant
donné que vous même vous maintenant
avait décidé de participer à la
résolution des problèmes antérieurs
aussi du pays comment
voyez vous la possibilité de punir ces
deux points de vue pour trouver un
compromis entre la stabilité le
développement
merci je
d'accord avec vous que ces régions ne
vivent pas comme moscou et que
finalement les décisions qui ont été
annoncées par le président au forum
économique orientale sont très
importantes c'est important de
développer
la sibérie orientale de
proposer des avantages financiers et
fiscaux tout cela c'est important et est
donc ces mesures vont prendre une forme
maintenant au concrètes je me déplace
dans le pays en plus de mes déplacements
professionnels j'aime beaucoup l'altaï
et
me promenais dans sur les rivières de
montagne et les villes de montagne les
villes de province donc tout ce qui se
passe
on voit on voit bien les priorités qui
se posent aujourd'hui à l'ordre du jour
du gouvernement du président le
gouvernement a déjà préparé un certain
nombre de mesures qui vont prendre une
forme juridique ici et qui sont voués à
soutenir les régions en ce qui concerne
la stabilité le développement
l'essentiel
c'est que il faut pas que ce soit deux
notions qui s'excluent dans la pratique
la stabilité elle est importante
nous voyons que dans certains pays de
l'espace postsoviétique
la stabilité
à était contraire aux ambitions
il ya des promesses qui ne sont pas
respectées et je suis d'accord avec ceux
qui
disent qu'on peut faire toujours mieux
et meilleur évidemment c'est partout
pareil on peut toujours faire mieux ça
c'est clair mais je suis d'accord avec
ceux qui disent que
qu'il faut promettre ce qu'on est en
mesure de réaliser et je pense que nos
forces politiques justement comprennent
bien les
le quel est le budget du pays quels sont
les les possibilités qu'on a au niveau
national et donc là faut voir quelles
sont les possibilités et on les forces
politiques vont pas proposer ce qui
n'est pas réalisable et donc
dans chaque campagne électorale
tous les partis qui sont
conscients de la responsabilité ça je
pense que c'est très bien
les gens veulent plus de développement
et je cite les
les exemples qui correspondent aux
résolutions du président mais les gens
ne veulent pas de répétition du maiden
ou des révolutions de couleur ça c'est
certain ils ne veulent pas que notre
nous à faire pas seulement étrangères
mais intérieur aussi voit une ingérence
étrangère
beaucoup
n'ont pas connu
les dernières années de l'empiré
soviétique et les premières de la presse
mais
quand il y avait dans des banques on
avait des conseillers
qui allaitent d'argent déterminer notre
action il ya encore une autre situation
c'est que
contrairement à d'autres pays de
l'espace postsoviétique
malgré tout les russes ont un sentiment
de fierté nationale
[Musique]
cette dignité se doit s'accompagner de
suffisance en soi si on peut dire c'est
des choses comme ça et si on combine ces
deux aspects je pense qu'on arrivera à
quelque chose de bon et le gouvernement
et le président cherche justement à
remplir cette cet objectif à atteindre
cet objectif
nous avons avec eux nous sommes
uniques et leurs représentants de
dagestan un journaliste héroïque qui a
travaillé dans de nombreux points chauds
des hostilités qui leur est à dupuy le
plume d'or membres du conseil de l'union
des journalistes aussi est lui aussi le
poser une question à celui-ci le micro
s'il vous plaît
monsieur le ministre la question n'est
pas liée à la politique
je connais que vous êtes fan de football
et maintenant est-ce que vous suivez de
près le jeu de notre sélectionne
renouvelée pendant ses matches dans le
cadre du futur championnat du monde et
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire sur les
premiers pas de nouvel entraîneur de la
sélection
alors comment le spartak son quartier ne
peut fonctionner ils sont inséparables
donc forcément
évidemment je suis l'actualité
je ne dors pas tant que le match n'est
pas terminé je suis
préoccupé je vois que tout ne marche pas
il ya eu des titres dans la presse
on a un résultat mais ya pas de jeu
c'est un peu dur je trouve d'autant plus
ce quartier n'a reçu
l'équipe
tout récemment c'est tout frais il
appelle temps de se préparer
je suis d'accord avec le fait j'ai lu
une interview de m i malin je sais qu'il
disait que
qui est une légende du football russe
qui a dit clairement que karpine devrait
réussir je l'espère beaucoup
je pense que c'était pas juste
dans la dernière saison
sparta qui était en 2e position
karpine
le un peu reproché et ça m'a paru
injuste je le soutiens et vu la réaction
des joueurs je pense qu'il a bien agi
encore une collègue
présentez vous s'il vous plaît bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur le roch je viens de le
city du nord alléno gourvat étant donné
qu'ils n'entreront dans cette ville des
vacances ma question va concerner les
vacances et le repos vous voyagez
beaucoup vous avez visité de nombreux
pays de nombreuses villes et vous
personnellement au ou aimez vous reposer
et qu'est-ce que vous adhérez à sotchi
tout me plaît à sotchi en ce qui
concerne
mon loisir préféré c'est du raft sur les
rivières de montagne et
et en hiver j'essaie d'aller dans les
régions de sibérie
avec des amis en général ça marche après
en ce qui concerne
d'autres d'ailleurs je suis venu dans
votre
chez vous j'ai été dans les gorges au
pied des montagnes et donc
je me soucie du coup je me dis
maintenant pourquoi pas aller en ossétie
du nord c'est magnifique là bas venez
encore soulever
merci d'ailleurs vous pour répondre à la
question de votre collègue dan ossétie
du sud
je vous remercie et encore en collègue
qui s'est présenté comme étant donné le
nombre de téléfilms multimédia
je représente la chaîne youtube serafim
vous êtes blogueur way plutôt le tort
aux blogueurs ou je suis l'auteur de la
chaîne youtube sert film on dit youtuber
ça se dit youtuber pourquoi pas j'aime
ça se fait qu'on apprend le lot
on monsieur ministre
avant tout je tiens à vous inviter à
participer à notre canal nous sommes
jeunes g avant 4-1 et nous débattons de
multiples problèmes lié avant tout à la
religion mais aussi à la politique et
aux arts des rires aux mains vous
tenez le discours en parlant de la
religion orthodoxe et la situation dans
le monde déclare les religieux
orthodoxes de questions vous avez
mentionné que l'église orthodoxe russe
est sous très forte pression des pays
étrangers avant tout des états unis qui
aspirent à détruire l'unité de
l'orthodoxie mondiale vous avez déjà dit
au début de notre rencontre
d'aujourd'hui que les journalistes
doivent bien vérifier les faits dit s'il
vous plaît pourquoi vous avez dit ça
pour quoi vous croyez que les etats-unis
disent à désintégrer l'unité de l'église
orthodoxe
en espérant de faire perdre cette union
est une autre question vous avez parlé
qu on avait dit que l'église orthodoxe
russe un véhicule les valeurs us à
l'étranger ce qui favorise à la
protection des intérêts à l'étranger
d'où vient ma question
quand vous est-ce que les propos pareils
ne contribue pas à renforcer la
réputation de l'église orthodoxe russe
dans le monde compte tenu de cette
perception de la politique extérieure
russe un conte voirie et dans certains
pays occidentaux
à force d'avouer ce partenariat c'est la
réputation de l'église est au dessus ce
qui peut en souffrir est ce que vous
vous allez accepté notre invitation pour
venir à notre chère la question c'était
les déclarations sur le fait que les
américains cherché à saper la position
de la l'orthodoxie on le sait je le sais
je le cache pas sous trump il y avait un
représentant spécial pour la liberté de
confession je me souviens plus de son
nom de famille est la personne qui
s'occupe de la liberté de confession
travailler activement à convaincre le
patriarche barthélémy de constantinople
de reconnaître les
[Musique]
les schismatiques de d'ukraine
et faire que ceux
qui étaient
ils ont nommé leur propre metropolit en
ukraine est aujourd'hui la préoccupation
principale
c'est de retirer ses propriétés à
l'église d'ukraine
d'obédience du patriarcat de moscou et à
l'occasion des 30 ans d'indépendance de
l'ukraine et donc c'est dit ouvertement
dans la presse
[Musique]
c'est l'objectif
en tout cas c'est le patriarche
barthélémy de constantinople né il est
directement en dépendance des états unis
enfin de ceux qui travaillent la zunie
et là dessus et notamment sur le plan
financier
et ça ne concerne pas que le cren il ya
des informations selon lesquelles
il cherche à créer une
exaucé fall en biélorussie et vous avez
vu ce qui s'est passé au monténégro
quand le patriarche de serbie est venu
pour l'intronisation du métropolite
et donc il ya eu des manifestations qui
ont été inspirés
et le président adou kanabeach
qui ne peut pas se remettre de sa
défaite aux élections et c'est de créer
des problèmes à son gouvernement est
prêt à lutter contre
l'église orthodoxe avec l'aide de ses
amis américains
et donc on cherche à obliger le clergé
orthodoxe à reconnaître cette église
autocéphale en grèce c'est pareil les
églises ont trouvé enfin compromis avec
leur conscience
à chypre aussi
donc il ya aussi des
des idéaux c'est aussi mais
qui cherche à s'implanter aussi au
proche orient en afrique et donc il ya
aussi des tentatives
pour les pousser pour pousser aussi les
le patriarcat d'alexandrie
de
de jérusalem et dans d'autres pays comme
en albanie et en roumanie en bulgarie
dont il ya des pressions sur le clergé
orthodoxe donc
donc nous appelons officiellement à
laisser les églises en paix en ce qui
concerne l'activité internationale de
l'église orthodoxe russe est ce qu'elle
soutient la politique
étrangère russe nous ne nous appuyons
pas sur
ce que fait
l'occident vis-à-vis de là aussi pour
nous ce qui est important c'est le
peuple russe les citoyens russes où
qu'ils soient dans le monde qui puisse
avoir
un soutien un rappel spirituel et
retrouver les codes les traditions
qu'ils connaissent et les valeurs que
défend l'église orthodoxe russe la
famille les enfants la jeunesse
l'éducation de la jeunesse
et tout cela correspond tout à fait à
nos programmes
et aux dernières dispositions qui ont
été prises par le président et qui
reflète
tout à fait
l'esprit de notre peuple l'âme de notre
peuple
et
la mise en oeuvre de notre politique et
nous cherchons à
apporter un soutien à cette démarche
en ce qui concerne
les acteurs qui se servent justement du
fait que l'église défend ses valeurs de
famille de jeunesse
et qui
cherchent
et qui ont une approche néo libérale
agressive
parce que l'église est une de celles qui
résistent justement à cette pression sur
les gens et qui
résistent
à 7 ans dorment endormissement à la
manière occidentale
et donc évidemment ce gens se livrent à
des attaques contre l'église orthodoxe
russe et si on regarde ce qui se passe
un peu innocent mais même par exemple en
ukraine occidentale
souvent les représentants de l'église
orthodoxe du patriarcat de moscou ring
qualifié de l'église de poutine
si vous lisez dans les blogs tout ce
qu'on dit sur
poutine sur les ministes de notre
gouvernement sur moi sur tout le monde
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya pas d'autres
sources d'information ont été vous voyez
les manifestations qui a eu contre
la venue de barthélémy et
et d'autres représentants poutine s'est
pas poutine qui les a poussés à
descendre dans la rue
c'est à dire que la fois un des piliers
de l'humanité ses pieds que disparaît
c'est un pays qui imposent les
valeurs néolibérales partout
voilà nous redit mais laissez les
enfants tranquilles donc vous voyez
toutes ces manifestations
et vous viendrez à notre chaîne
regardée avec maria celle qui elle
travaille avec les blogueurs les
youtuber
vous donner des buts et longtemps
présenté vous ces deux nations data va
je représente une région
avoisinante la région de mourmansk haut
c'est la nageuse est pas reconnue en
cette robe bonjour vous savez ma
question suivante en 2019 vous avez tenu
parole en norvège et en quarts kenneth
pour
la commémoration de la libération de
norvège du nord des troupes nazies
c'était des festivités et vous avez
parlé que notre frontière avec la
norvège et c'est parmi les frontières
les plus paisibles parce que nous avons
jamais fait la guerre contre de nos
religions et c'était le gage de notre
bon voisinage mais à c'était en 2019 en
2020 mode mars les frontières hausses
ont été refermées et nos contacts avec
les journalistes avec boison au
continent ont persisté et dernièrement
je ressens un peu de froid de la part de
mes collègues norvégiens on me traite
non pas comme cette notion d'intérêt de
russie mais comme quelqu'un de l'union
soviétique
cet isolement des pays y compris des
pays européens à l'encontre de la russie
commence à en flux ans la perception de
notre pays par les peuples des pays
occidentaux est ce que on peut regagner
la situation d'avant la pandémie ou le
monde du futur sera tout à fait autres
les perceptions de l'est russie sera
différente je reviens à ce que ce par
quoi j'ai comme ça nous sommes ouverts à
toute coopération si cette coopération
se fait de façon honnête et droite
multilatérale à ce moment là nous sommes
d'accord et ne voulons pas que nos
voisins nos partenaires quels qu'ils
soient prennent des mesures
qui créent des risques pour notre
sécurité
la norvège a une loi selon laquelle il
ne doit pas y avoir de présence de
troupes étrangères armée
et dans le cadre de cette machine
d'extension de l'otan
et il ya l'acte fondateur des relations
entre
l'otan et la russie des tic qu' il n'y
aura pas de d'implantation d'armes
à proximité de la la frontière russe
mais par exemple dans les pays baltes en
norvège
on voit des brigades
canadienne canadiennes anglaises
allemandes
s'installer
et
quand on a demandé à madame la ministre
pourquoi il y avait ses troupes elle à
dire mais c'est simplement une rotation
n'y a rien mais tout cela est bien
triste parce que nous n'avons donné
aucun motif
nous avons toujours bien travailler avec
nos collègues nos partenaires
norvégien dans des relations
de respect mutuel de même que nous avons
signé un accord sur la limitation des
déploiements d'armes dans la mer de
barents par exemple et nous avons trouvé
les forces de travailler pour trouver un
équilibre des forces nous avons un
régime
de
notre
de franchissement des frontières sans
visa avant le sommaire qui naissent
j'avais été
aussi au 70e anniversaire
de la libération des occupants allemands
et j'avais été touché par l'attention
qu'ils nous avaient été accordés et le
roi était là et le premier ministre le
ministre des affaires étrangères
et c'est tout cela avait été fait
sur une grande place dans la vie il y
avait énormément de monde les gens
étaient habillés en costumes
traditionnels avec des drapeaux
norvégiens et russes
et en plus
tout ce groupe dirigé par le roi le
premier ministre
avait été
procédé à un dépôt de gerbe sur la tombe
des soldats russes donc nous avons
des désaccords avec la norvège en
matière économique sur le territoire de
spitzberg par exemple il y à des
consultations sur la façon
d'appliquer le traité de sur le speed
faire de 1920 et si on ait l'impression
que il cherchait à se fermer
alors je vais sénat enseigner mais je
vais dire juste moi même en tant que
témoin direct j'avais vu
cette effusion de sentiments donc
donc après la pandémie j'espère que
petit à petit toutes ces restrictions
vont se lever et qu'on va
retrouver peut-être
certains difficile pour l'instant de
dire quand elles seront complètement
levé puisque les médecins les
scientifiques réfléchissent aux blanche
juste voit encore en collègues qui
demandent depuis longtemps le micro
bonsoir aujourd'hui c'est le festival de
leusse et y ait des normes
moi je représente aussi ses sept minutes
oui vous êtes très nombreux qui est
appelé hier la télévision nationale de
l'esthétique denard
le caucase du nord est connu pour son
potentiel touristique actuellement le
style du nord et parmi a parmi les
missions clés de développement de ce
domaine d'hospitalité qu'est-ce qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire pour attirer non
seulement les tories les touristes
russes mais aussi l'été les touristes
étrangers et je vais profiter de cette
occasion pour vous inviter tous au
festival
l'adedy pour faire venir les touristes
moi je qu'est-ce que et fauche moi je me
demande ce qu'il faut faire pour que les
relations avec la norvège sa mère si
vous
répondez pour les responsables pour les
informations de
l'os et y vous comme spécialiste je suis
pas spécialiste de touristes mais faites
en sorte que votre patrie
s'épanouissent et soit florissante
et conservant ce festival des attaques
traditionnelles c'est le 25 26 septembre
peut-être
envoyer notre république est très
intéressante
multinationale peut être il faut retenir
notre addition au en faire le centre
d'attractivité
pourquoi pas faire la maintenance il à
la tradition et puis en même temps
ne vous retenez pas et n'ai pas
ramené de des tartes et gâteaux
traditionnels alexandre ivanov ce qui
est des gratteurs en chef de deux
quotidiens profits et secrétaire de
l'union des journalistes de russie
sur le ministre ces derniers temps un os
témoignant des restrictions massives qui
sont déposés haute fonctionnement de nos
médias à l'étranger on voit toujours des
agressions contre rasht usd contre ce
britannique pour en riposte aux ne sont
obligés de prendre des mesures à
similaires
s'il vous plaît dites nous quelle est
votre vision de cette situation de la
guerre non déclarée à contre les médias
et qu'est ce qui pourrait offrir la
guerre est quasiment
déclarée et maria sharapova on parle
très régulièrement le diffuse des
documents là dessus et surtout des faits
parce que par exemple quand on demande
après deux ans de patience et d'attentes
pour que les anglais donnent des visas
aux représentants de
tasses
ils ont été privé d'accréditation peu
puis 2019 et nous avons prévenu mais
nous ne voulons pas que les journalistes
souffrent de cela mais nous allons être
obligés de répondre de riposter de la
même façon
donc on a demandé à leurs représentants
de bbc de partir on lui a expliqué à
l'ats elle a tout compris elle était
désolée elle est partie tout de suite
elle a tout de suite
déversé des torrents de haine sur nous
la bbc a fait des déclarations il ya
beaucoup d'exemples comme ça
aujourd'hui même par exemple il a été
déclaré que les
cérémonies dieu 11
septembre
les représentants russes étaient de la
presse russe était privé d'accréditation
aux états unis
[Musique]
oui j'ai vu qu'il ya une réclamation de
l'union des journalistes quand
ce groupe anonymous a
découvert ça doit être des reculs que
mon travail qui ont découvert des
documents qui montrait que le foreign
office office
travailler directement réglées médias en
leur donnant des documents leur disant
comment les présenter pour accuser la
fédération de russie hélas ce fait rien
et quand
facebook par exemple
à obliger nos
agences de presse à marquer leurs
produits
comme fait sous le contrôle d'un état
c'est ria novosti tasse et à septembre
d'autres mais fait la bbc appareils
financés par l'état
il aimait nous nous c'est la démocratie
chez vous c'est autre chose c'est
l'autocratie jeu c'est ridicule où ça
serait ridicule
mais ils promeuvent leurs méthodes
notamment via les organisations
internationales
et c'est à dire que en marge des
organisations internationales exemple
unesco qui s'occupe de la formation
de l'éducation
en face de ça en plus de ça par exemple
les français annonce des partenariats
internationale de lutte contre les
sectes nous dans l'espace médiatique e71
avec plusieurs dizaines de personnes qui
veut dimanche visiblement partagent les
points de vue français c'est elle qui
travaille sur les normes qui veulent eux
appliquer
sans alternative sans avis haletante et
après et nous présente ça comme la
vérité
toute nue
et donc ses partenaires
sans
frontières ils sont par une heureuse
coïncidence juste un mot c'est à paris
elles ont dit que deux se sont
ils bénéficient de financements sous
couvert de l'unesco alors que l'unesco
comme
association union internationale
travaille déjà sur ces questions par
exemple air terre voulait accréditer
le nez ce qu on leur a dit
vous n'êtes pas admis aux conférences de
presse de l'elysée c'est normal ça pour
une organisation internationale
donc on a des gens qui sont
spécialistes dans ça il ya un nom si je
me sens et demi je sais il y avait une
loi contre les faits que nous dans la
presse qui avait été adopté par la
chambre basse mais qui n'a pas été
adopté par le sénat mais en même temps
ils l'ont quand même mise en oeuvre
c'est à dire que un juge peut bloquer un
média pendant 48 heures 1 je joue
simplement
et le sénat n'avait pas soutenu cette
loi
donc la loi de l'égalité ici n'est pas
tout à fait respecté
je sais même pas quoi vous dire de plus
il faut lutter pour la vérité
kelly chine ce qui
représente
je te drt
mais c'est la preuve il ya pas longtemps
vous avez dit que la russie
n'utilisera pas la force pour protéger
les droits de nos ressortissants en
étranger à l'étranger c'est pas notre
style mais les russes y voient exigées
les responsabilités pour la violation
des droits de nos ressortissants en
profitant des plateformes
internationales
quand vous en tant qu ministre en tant
qu'
une personnalité parmi la liste des
dents departed en majeure partie du pays
pour les élections législatives les
droits de nos compatriotes qui sont
garanties par notre constitution
est ce qu'il serait plus facile et plus
efficace
à protéger les droits de nos
compatriotes en projettant
la
vigueur de cette loi à l'échelle ex
territoriales une tune on peut être à
transformer les phoques les formules de
la loi pour protéger notre histoire
notre simple nos symboles à d'état notre
langue
quelle est votre appréciation de cette
idée de créer une loi pareille
l'idée que vous avez exposé notamment en
matière de recevabilité du passé elle
est déjà mise en oeuvre de cette
initiative du parti russie unie
qui a proposé des amendements la
législation et le procureur général a
aussi proposé de poursuivre
la négation de ce que nous portons au
coeur du point de vue historique en ce
qui concerne la loi de soutien aux
compatriotes
mais en raison de l'article 69 de la
constitution
vous savez je dirige une commission
intergouvernementale
et nous avons déjà travaillé c'est bien
après
les élections nous allons voir les
modifications on peut apporter à cette
fois je suis d'accord avec le fait qu'
il faut inscrire cela de façon détaillée
ces choses qui sont relatives aux droits
de nos concitoyens et notamment dans les
pays où ils se trouvent cet important
landais pipe les piliers la base d'un
trait union ce sont les journaux
régionaux juge wadia naguère baldé
rédactrice en chef du journal à la voie
de la vérité qui préside l union des
journalistes de les régions de coups
gagnants
bonsoir monsieur lavrov je représente
des médias traditionnels qui
évidemment anime son site internet et
ses réseaux sociaux ne voyons que les
gens sont de plus en plus nombreux de
chercher l'information
parmi les médias non traditionnels le
blogueur sont de plus en plus nombreux
les tictacs heure-ci dont nombreux
prétendent devenir les leaders d'opinion
publique et certains d'entre eux le sont
déjà
ma question c'est quelle est votre
attitude envers les nouveaux médias qui
ne travaillent pas dans le cadre de la
loi régissant le fonctionnement des
médias et vous même vous puisé votre en
formation aux actualités de kiel source
vis-à-vis
des
moyens
nouveaux
de communication je pense que ils sont
qui sont des moyens comme les autres il
ya 20 ans par exemple ça n'existait pas
je me souviens encore de l'époque
et on savait simple si on n'avait pas de
coppet que pour mettre dans un téléphone
public et ben on ne pouvait pas prévenir
qu'on est en retard donc la société dans
mon dévolu
oui évidemment c'est séduisant on en
parle beaucoup il ya des reportages là
dessus dans les réseaux sociaux où on
voyait que des jeunes des très jeunes
décident que c'est plus facile pour eux
de d'organiser leur blog s'ils ont une
certaine popularité et s'ils ont un
soutien et que je pas besoin de faire
des études je suis convaincu que ce ne
sont que des cas particuliers et il faut
voir ces opportunités comme un don il
faut les utiliser vous avez dit que vous
avez parlé des
médias traditionnels
mais nous c'est pareil on au ministère
en particulier avec madame diallo va
nous avons développé nous développons
chaque jour de plus en plus notre
présence dans les réseaux sociaux
notamment dans les langues étrangères
est aussi
d'autres modalités de communication sur
internet
se concurrencent elles se complètent
vis-à-vis des médias traditionnels et à
votre exemple on voit que l'on peut
combiner tout cela et je pense je suis
pas expert dans cette technologie mais
je pense qu'il y a le moyen de combiner
tout
ces formes qui sont promus pour les
auditeurs les spectateurs et voir ce qui
est le plus efficace je pense qu'on doit
avoir les moyens justement d'analyser
tout ça aujourd'hui
sans écouter tout le monde
s'en va surtout mettre d'obstacles mais
encore une fois je le souligne je vois
le défi essentiel c'est que la qualité
du journalisme traditionnel
doit être transféré dans le domaine de
la blogosphère c'est difficile voire
peut-être impossible mais je vends
collègues qui est près de caméras qui
tient s'amender vous êtes de ceux çi non
je veux passer la parole à quelqu'un de
sotchi c'est qui
oui je vous passerais parole avait
ensuite la jeune fille de sophie bonjour
je ne suis pas de ceux qui les
représentent les régions asiatiques et
je voudrais reprendre la question sur
les compatriotes
moi je présente un journal pour les
compatriotes dès 2006 et je représente
comme j'ai déjà dit la région asiatique
donc
au début de la pandémie de nombreux
compatriotes ont dû
quitter les pays de leur séjour pour
rentrer en russie la russie a
proposé de multiples programmes de
rapatriement mais c'était pas tous ceux
qui auront su profiter de ses programmes
d'autant plus que le délai de ce jour
tant peur n'était pas imprévisible
ces gens reste maintenant à russie mais
ils restent bloqués dans le pays ils ne
peuvent pas rentrer dans le pays de leur
séjour qu'ils ont quittée à pour en
certain temps et pendant plusieurs
années ils ont travaillé pour promouvoir
la culture russe la langue russe en
servant de 7
force douce ils peuvent pas rentrer dans
leur pays de séjour monsieur lavrov on
avait plus besoin de nous non vous savez
ces compatriotes qui nous vive qui
vivent autour de nous notamment dans les
pays de l'ex espace souhaitais je veux
pas dire que c'est une réserve non je
pense que ça doit se faire naturellement
l'essentiel c'est que les gens se
sentent bien
et ensemble ils sont peut-être une un
soft power il ya le soutien à la langue
russe à la culture russe mais ça
concerne aussi les relations de bon
voisinage avec les pays dans lesquels
ils vivent il ya un processus de de
concorde nationale
et notre gouvernement depuis l'époque
des tsars je n'ai pas entendu que ses
compatriotes et fait part de problèmes
particuliers en tout cas dans notre
commission qui examine toutes ces
questions n'a pas reçu il ya eu des
plaintes mais est-ce que ce programme va
soutenir les gens qui n'arrivent pas à
rentrer mais je veux comprendre de quoi
vous parlez ils peuvent parvenir où ils
peuvent pas rester
ils sont déjà rentrés en russie mais ils
ne peuvent pas recommencer leur vie en
russie vous avez dit qu'ils savent pas
quand ils pourront revenir dans tes sont
en suspens nous savons pas si nous
allons avoir la possibilité d rentrée
tout est déjà détruit on a plus de
business n'a plus d'ambiance on ne veut
plus de nous mais nous avons mis
plusieurs années à travailler pour
protéger deux compatriotes pour
promouvoir la ne trouveront pas de
travail travaillez-vous travailler avec
moi j'étais âgé présidé l'union des
compatriotes à thaïlande nous
parler de sa vie mais si vous avez une
expérience pareille il faut bien qu'ils
aient quelqu'un qui unissent toutes ces
personnes qui manifestent leurs voeux
oui oui peut-être faut le faire
et la question de les inclure dans le
programme de
réimplantation des compatriotes ça fait
partie du département des migrations le
programme a été lancé un petit peu de
façon sceptique mais en tout cas même si
encore des obstacles bureaucratiques
qui continue à se maintenir un peu
partout mais il ya quand même des
centaines de personnes qui ont déménagé
moi je veux comprendre qu'ils sont ce
genre il ya eu les gens qui étaient
bloquées par la pandémie on sait que les
gens gens savent qu'ils doivent rester
un certain nombre de un certain temps
dans le dos mais simplement les gens
avec qui tu es la pandémie donc c'est un
processus selon année donc il faut
organiser ça oui c'est pas organisé pour
le moment alors quelle est l'ampleur et
c'est aller au bureau de migration
krasnodar on m'a dit que pour profiter
profiter de ce programme le rapatriement
il faut s'adresser à l'ambassade russe
dans le pays de votre arrivée là je vais
faire entrer présence et c'est ça que je
veux dire c'est que c'est une nouvelle
catégorie de personnes et d'une façon ou
d'une autre elle doit se former et j'ai
connu tout seul on essaie de soulever
cette question encore une fois durant le
congrès ici c'est possible encore une un
petit commentaire nous voulons nous
adresser dans le cadre du 7ème congrès
avec l'initiative
d'introduire une nouvelle fête en russie
la journée deux compatriotes c'est une
bonne idée
nous allons passer les paroles associés
mais avant je passais parole de lire tes
hanches et d'augmenter factea it girl
cherniak et c'est déjà longtemps qu'il
le demande la parole
c'est l'épreuve
si vous permettait encore deux mots
concernant l'afghanistan qui a été déjà
mentionné la russie a fait partie des
six pays que les talibans ont invité à
assister à l'inauguration du
gouvernement
c'était irain l'arabie saoudite la chine
la turquie le qatar et la russie à mon
point de vue c'est un bon signe et le
pakistan oui pakistan à mon point de vue
c'est bien de
d'être nommé parmi ce nombre restreint
des pays
et ensuite on s'est posé la question qui
devrait représenter les russies
valentina matvienko a refusé on a
proposé la candidature de l'ambassadeur
ensuite monsieur peskov le porte parole
présidentiel a dit que la russie
n'allait pas participer ensuite les
taliban ont déclaré que la libération
n'aurait pas lieu le 11 comme c'était
prévu d'avancé qu'est-ce qui se passe il
se passe exactement ce dont vous en
parlent et échangent leurs plans tous
les jours et notamment ceux qui
concernent
l'inclusivité du processus politique ils
ont déclaré nous annonce un gouvernement
qui était 100% un membre de toutes les
banques mais avec de logiques mais qui
sont allés pense et puis après ils ont
dit quand les gens commencent à réagir
dans d'autres pays
oui mais c'est pour nous c'est un
gouvernement de transit et durera un
gouvernement inclusif et donc vous avez
raison il avait annoncé
l'investiture et puis après ils ont
changé d'avis je vous dis franchement
nous n'avions jamais l'intention de
recommander à nos dirigeants de d'être
présent sur place dans une délégation de
moscou je dis simplement que
le
lan basse adore mais avait récusé cette
idée même au niveau des masques de
l'ambassade non non pas en nous ce
serait mais il y aura pas de suite
puisque lorsque les russes il n'allait
pas participer ce que je veux dire c'est
que deux mots scoop personne c'est pas
être les gens refusent c'est que ici le
problème réside dans le fait que
eux-mêmes
mélangez un petit peu les priorités ici
il n'y a pas de ruse ou deux c'est clair
la deuxième question si vous permettez
il y a quelques jours
le que lui tour des négociations
entre les présidents russe et biélorusse
a pris fin on a signé plusieurs dizaines
d'accords tout à fait différent vous
êtes en participant de ce processus que
ce que vous pouvez nous dire est ce qu
on assiste à cette percée attendue
depuis longtemps dans nos relations
quelles sont d'après vous les principaux
accords parmi ceux qui ont été signés
est votre point de vue elle c est réel
de former dans la vie lui reproche une
devise unique en parlement unis où
quelques autres choses du nid le
président n'a rien signé ils se sont
rencontrés avant-hier à moscou ils ont
examiné les documents qui avaient été
préparés par les gouvernements et la
signature s'est faite aujourd'hui et
pourquoi je suis arrivé un petit peu en
retard par rapport à leurs qui était
prévu justement parce que j'étais à
minsk
à la réunion des gouvernements de l'état
d'union des deux pays
et des orientations principales
pour le plan d'action pour les années
2002 2022 2023 donc il ya 28 programmes
de coopération qui vise l'harmonisation
de tous nos mécanismes économiques
agricoles juridique
l'harmonisation et
monétaire social
crédit terre au niveau des frontières et
tout cela et
le document cadre comprend des
obligations politiques et
il doit être
transcrits dans les modalités
juridiques qui vont être élaborés par le
gouvernement très prochainement
ce qui est un pur semble ici c'est que
il
insiste sur le rôle politique
et créer une base complémentaire
pour
améliorer la situation économique de
l'état de l'union
en ce qui concerne la monnaie unique
le l'union parlementaire hier on en a
parlé en détail le président poutine et
le président loukachenko on parlait
justement de ces questions
une monnaie unique n'exclut pas
justement donc une assemblée
parlementaire
commune n'est pas exclue non plus donc
c'est un travail qui se fait petit à
petit et il ya un bloc économique qui
est très important et c'est lui qui est
bien
ensuite on verra ce qu'il faut faire sur
les autres programmes
et maintenant les représentants des
médias de sotchi
présentez-vous clp je m'appelle jean
acédo va moskovski komsomolets
alors mais vous êtes de ceux çi oui
alors
moi j'ai beaucoup ma ville
nous adorons
lorsque les invités viennent chez nous
récemment nous avons eu cette
possibilité de délivrer les visas
électronique le même visa électronique
est
réalisé dans d'autres villes de notre
pays est ce que ce visa électronique
sera disponible sur tout le territoire
national
et d'après vous
comme est ce que le tourisme reprendra
sa valeur son échelle etc en vue la
forme possible de la pandémie de la
vaccination c'est bien que vous aimez
sotchi tout en vous procurant de
l'ensemble du pays c'est très bien les
visa électronique
du 1er janvier
2021 fonctionne sur l'ensemble du
territoire il ya eu des régions pilotes
l'extrême orient kaliningrad et ensuite
saint pétersbourg et la région de saint
pétersbourg et depuis le 1er janvier
2021 les visa électronique s'applique
sur l'ensemble du territoire de la
fédération de russie leur application
pratique a été retardée par la pandémie
la relève pas de mes responsabilités
mais c'est lié à la diffusion
du bon ami et de madame golikova qui
gère justement les réponses à donner à
cette pandémie
ici au gouvernement évidemment nous
sommes pour que le touriste se développe
c'est une question très important
puisque vous avez vu par exemple il ya
une reprise des infections en israël où
elle avait quasiment disparu
d'ailleurs hier j'étais avec eux le
nouveau ministre israélien et je lui ai
demandé
pourquoi sur ces questions de tourisme
d'un pan de vie pourquoi ils ont pris il
ya quelques jours
[Musique]
il laisse venir les étrangers avec des
vaccins
reconnu
en israël et dans l'union européenne
mais pourquoi dans cette liste il n'y a
pas nos vaccins il a promis de
travailler là dessus donc ce passage aux
flux touristiques concret
va se faire mais je crois que sotchi n'a
jamais été fermé
juste un peu oui d'accord mais petit à
petit tout ceci va s'alléger mais je le
répète encore une fois je ne suis pas
spécialiste mais via mes collègues je
suis confronté à ça c'est mes collègues
de la sécurité sanitaire dans le monde
donc si tout le monde avance à tâtons
parce que personne ne sait exactement
comment vont se présenter les prochaines
vagues
on a trop peu de données pour faire des
prévisions à long terme et donc prendre
des décisions
opportunes donc tout le monde est
intéressé à ce que le tourisme
reprennent des décisions ont été prises
justement pour dire que certains disent
que la pandémie ça y est c c'est
définitif et où on l'aura tout le monde
et on va lever les sanctions et au
mondial se levant encore une question
excusez moi une question par personne on
a déjà à peu près deux heures
[Musique]
de notre rencontre il ne reste que je
pense trois questions
leurs différents chefs d'un journal sur
un ca 9 veut poser de questions
messieurs lavrov série victor erice pour
poursuivre la question de mon collègue
qui a
demandé le football on connaît que vous
adorez la poésie et vous écrivez
vous-même les poésies et vous vous êtes
l'auteur de textes et de l'hymne de
l'institut
des relations internationales
de moscou et elle a aujourd'hui durant
se feront des journalistes de russie
mais ceux là vont après les élections
après toutes ces difficultés
est-ce que vous pourrez être trouvé le
temps pour écrire les paroles pour
l'hymne de forums mois des journalistes
pour ce forum oui d'autant plus ce que
vous connaissez beaucoup sur l'activité
des journalistes dans le monde entier
je remercie pour votre bonne parole mais
qui le poète je l'avais dit
les
les poèmes ccre il souffre inspiration à
doc on va espérer on va espérer et nous
avec eux série victorieuse avons fait
les études dans la même école dans le
ville de guise qui me l'avait pas dit
vous n'avez pas parlé oui c'est l'école
numéro de coraline côte et vous avez
écrit l'épaule et poésie consacré à
notre école et à l'école on s'en
rappelle encore je vous interromps il ya
un moment amusant il y avait le chef de
l'administration de nos casques et la
demande et
nous rencontrons ces
rencontres il avait j'avais passé mon
enfance auprès de mes grands parents là
bas
dans un petit village rue georgia
c'est la limite de 9 guinn sq la limite
de la ville
où il y avait des maisons
en bois
donc on allait chercher de l'eau à la
fontaine et il y avait un stade
qui s'appelait spartak on joue au foot
après il ya le palet d'or aussi et donc
le chef d'administration vient me voir
et je croyais pas j'en croyais pas mes
yeux il m'envoyait une esquisse comment
des
instructeurs qui était pour une statue
en mon honneur dans l'école
mais j'ai laissé une photo quand même si
des lectrices à l'école dans la zone
d'honneur nous avons trop apport très
patriote qui minent vous et moi
excusez moi
encore une question à chaque design le
secrétaire de l'union des journalistes
de russie bonsoir
monsieur le ministre
ma question concerne l'espace de l'ex
urss en russie ont réalisé un projet le
pays des possibilités est ce qu on peut
faire participer à ce projet d'autres
participants comment faire de manière qu
les
voisins les pays de l'ex urss se sentent
qu'ils ont des mêmes possibilités oui la
russie est un pays deux opportunités il
faut développer tout ça il ya beaucoup
de projets il ya les leaders de russie
par exemple avec une orientation
internationale
donc j'ai dirigé online une
rencontre qu'on s'être créé à ce
problème il y avait
plus de 1000 demandes de 150 pays pour
la russie c'est des centaines de
milliers c'est du travail oui
c'est des gens ambitieux bon sens du
terme et qui veulent justement profiter
de ces opportunités il ya un ascenseur
social
appelez le comme vous voulez mais en
face et la possibilité de choisir une
profession
d'améliorer ses commandes ses
connaissances
d'avoir un stimulant pour se développer
et moi je lève les demain pour ça et
encore une question à la jeune fille
n'avait droit qu'à une question
chère collègue excusez moi s'il vous
plaît la dernière question je vais
l'usure peut aussi je vais le posez moi
même sept des victimes oui on a nos
portraits qui sont accrochées côté oui
nous avons ce droit
évidemment les collègues de l'occident
vous pose souvent cette question qu'est
ce que ce qu'est la russie comment
est-elle qu'est ce que vous répondez
peut-être c'est la question la plus
simple et la plus difficile en même
temps
on peut lire et saigner ne bouge qu'il
est d'autres grands poètes et écrivains
russes mais la russie
c'est la patrie c'est le pays où on en
est c'est nos ancêtres qu'on va voir
dont on va visiter les trompes ce sont
les enfants nos amis
le sensation d'avoir les racines ici et
c'est tout ça en son temps chacun à tout
cela donc si on met ça tout ça ensemble
et ben justement c'est la patrie c'est
l'amour de la patrie c'est le
patriotisme moi c'est comme ça que je
perçois
vous voyez c'est bien dans les écoles
d'apprendre ça et c'est horrible que les
manuels scolaires et des lacunes
considérables
là dessus sur la deuxième guerre
mondiale dans les conditions actuelles
c'est important notamment à notre époque
où il ya beaucoup de d'appareils mobiles
etc il faut que les enfants élèvent
leurs enfants
dans l'amour de la patrie du pays où ils
sont nés
et je pense que pour l'instant c'est
dans notre bagage génétique
et regarder souvent c'est ça on est dans
un état on va faire c'est d'ailleurs on
prend va vivre en europe nous sommes
peut-être plus conservatif du cercle
conservateur dans le bon sens du terme
donc prévu préserver tout cela merci
juste une dernière détails de notre
réunion nous avons un représentant au
serbe goran petrovic une personnalité
unique l'avocat qui a réuni à toul en
formation sur tout les crimes de l'otan
ont durant le bombardement de
yougoslavie il vient d'éditer un livre à
ce sujet c'est le lys et en livrant
russe et vous veut vous l'offrir
chers amis je pense qu aujourd'hui
chaque électeur à vichy nous a fait
preuve de l'ouverture du ministère des
affaires étrangères pour
la communication avec les journalistes
je suis persuadé que les citations de
notre
échange d'aujourd'hui volent des gens
peu partout dans les médias et
je tiens à remercier le ministre lavrov
pour cet entretien je vous remercie
merci à vous c'était très intéressant et
tout meilleurs et excellent forum à vous
tous